[Music]
okay hi everyone so I guess one question
you might reasonably ask is well why
should we need to change our patterns of
thought you know perhaps things are
going okay what's the what's the big
issue so I actually wanted to begin with
this picture that I'm sure a lot of you
will be recognizing from just last month
in London and I - um so of course this
is the extinction rebellion basically
closing down London for a few days to
raise awareness about climate breakdown
and just a show of hands is anybody in
there in the space here involve the
extinction rebellion anyway or and good
on you
great great lovely - to hear that we we
got to exactly really proud of a well
you who faced the possibility of
prosecution everything else for getting
involved with this so why were people
closing down London and to talk about
climate breakdown and of course the
reason is because the ways in which our
patents of thought have led to our
current civilization for all the good
things as brought has brought some
tremendous imbalances we're heading
towards such catastrophe and not just
climate breakdown even if we could fix
that we've got this incredible
ecological devastation we're facing some
of you may be aware of a report that
just came out from and thousands of UN
and scientists about the ecological
destruction going on they're talking
about how there may be as many as a
million species at risk now for
extinction and then it's not just
species extinction everywhere we look we
got a degradation in the ocean
deforestation and upcoming water crisis
this century each place we're over
consuming the earth and then it's of
course it's not just that look at the
credible inequalities greatest
inequalities probably in all of history
where just a handful of people own as
much wealth as half the entire world
population and then to obviously to
capital then we have other people
talking about the risk of AI taking over
from him from humanity or whatever so
things are looking like out of control
and question is like how did we get to
that place and what happened to humanity
to think in certain ways to lead us to
that and I spent a lot of my last 10
years or even more asking myself this
question and trying to look at the
underlying shapes of thinking that led
us to this place and what I got to and
realize in the end is that humans have a
distinct way of thinking that kind of
makes us unique among all other animals
is that we're driven to pattern meaning
into the world and I wrote a book came
out a couple years ago called the
patterning instinct a cultural history
of humanity search for meaning and what
I realized as I came to this place was
that that's patterning instinct that
humans have actually is what underlies
the values that a civilization develops
and that basically different cultures
create different sets of values and
those values shape history and when we
look at our current situation we
realized that by the same token the
values that we formed as a civilization
all of us around the world will shape
our future so to begin with let's look a
little bit more at this patterning
instinct and you know we can call it an
instinct because well even she has it so
a little infant just born nobody tells
her you know and you need to really
listen carefully to all the sounds you
get because we speak a thing called
language and you should figure that out
she just hears these different sounds
fuels these different feelings in
association with those sounds and
because she has this instinct to pattern
meaning into what goes on around her
before too long she begins to learn the
language and then the culture of
wherever she's born and SCIM
if we cast our minds back into the
earliest part of history the the dawn of
human history well the earliest humans
they just developed the ability to even
have language they'd look for example
they'd look at the world around them and
see something that might be City random
like just a star in the sky but they
would instantly want to put meaning into
it so every culture around the world say
put constellations into that they look
at those kind of random patterns and and
they say you know there's kind of
meaning there then here's one
constellation here's another so we're
going to look at some of those patterns
of meaning the different early cultures
actually put into the world around them
and we'll begin with the patterns of
early hunter-gatherers and we spent
about 95% of our human history our
ancestors were nomadic hunter-gatherers
is travelling around the world in small
bands and they saw their primary pattern
of meaning they saw nature like a giving
parent wherever they went there was food
for them they saw everything in nature
is having spirits they saw their own
spirits as being just part of all the
spirits of everything else in fact they
saw everything's always transforming so
their own spirit might have been an
animal spirit and would be again in the
future
they saw no boundaries between things
and they basically and saw it nature as
just something that was just there for
them and really a part of who they were
but that all changed about 12,000 years
or so ago with the rides of agriculture
and I love to use this kind of image
it's like Koenig image of a fence as
iconic in my mind for agriculture
because agriculture was really about was
the forming of separations in the human
experience he had separations between
and human cultivation and the sort of
wildness out there and in nature but you
also had separations between humans
because if people settled down and
started to go
have their own crops they started to
develop possessions and then the ones
who got lucky or worked a little bit
harder and had more crops then did
better than other people then they
wanted to protect their wealth and then
they might hire other people to work on
their fields and things like that and so
before too long you had things that we
take for granted just arrived in with
agriculture things like wealth hierarchy
and just a very sense of the value of
possessions as opposed to as opposed to
not you also see the rights of the
patriarchy and with with the rise of
Agriculture and so along with and the
specialization that that led to came
this like increasing strength of
hierarchies and people rather than just
being in egalitarian bands they had to
kind of say the right things to the
people in charge they had to basically
ultimately pay them homage payment
respect so they developed an a pattern
of understanding the universe based on
that kind of experience so they
developed a sense of the hierarchy of
the gods that nature was no longer just
this giving mother and father you had
this hierarchy and you'd better like
sacrifice to the gods and worship them
and just and the development men who
ritual just kind of show them how
wonderful you thought they were
otherwise they might like demolish your
fields and make your life like screw up
whatever so everywhere around the world
that's kind of pattern of thought
developed in all the early civilizations
Aztec Maya Inca China Indian Mesopotamia
Egypt everywhere you see that same kind
of pattern of thinking in different ways
but underlying and patent being the same
that then about 2,500 years ago in two
parts of the world for eastern China
different uniquely innovative patterns
of thinking occurred that really helped
to shape a lot of the human experience
since then well begin just to spend a
couple minutes looking at what this new
form of thinking was in China so some of
you may be familiar with some of these
signs the yin-yang sign a medal in fact
probably I talked about that before that
and the the these are signs of that
relate to the eaching which I'm sure
many of you heard of the and the actual
translation of each Inge is the Book of
Changes because the traditional Chinese
way of looking at the cosmos was the
yin-yang everything being interconnected
they actually took that Han together a
sense of things worth being transforming
but they kind of systematized it and
they saw all these webs of
interconnections ultimately existing in
one gigantic network patterns always
changing that they call the DAO and so a
lot of the early Chinese think has spent
that time sort of pondering the DAO
saying how can we sort of optimize the
human existence within this well this
cosmos of this totally changing patterns
and they they really kind of focused a
lot in the sense of harmonizing with the
DAO and they developed this sense this
kind of new pattern of understanding the
cosmos as being um what we can think of
as like a harmonic web of life and of
the web is a great sort of metaphor for
that because imagine you're walking in
the forest and you see a web there and
say connected to a tree or something
you know that just a tiny little drop of
water or just a leaf just sort of
touching that web will cause a whole set
of interconnected by vibrations and
resonance through the entire web and
that's how they saw the cosmos everyone
any one of us did had resonances
throughout the entire cosmos and the
humans the earth and the heavens so
meanwhile over a few thousand miles to
the west and greets at around the same
time a very different pattern of thought
emerge the podcast talks debates courses
and articles visit the Institute's of
art and ideas click the link on screen
now - ie TV